Follow Lane,
focus on facebook,
twitter,
and instagram.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange focus channel.
Uh,
my name is Paul.
Today's topic is the Indonesian language
or Bahasa,
Indonesia as it's called in Indonesian
Indonesian,
as closely connected with Malaya.
So if you haven't seen my video on the
Malay language yet,
I recommend that you watch that first
before you watched this video.
Indonesian is based on ballet,
though it has evolved and taken on some
uniquely Indonesian features.
There are about 43 million native
speakers of Indonesian and about
155000002nd language speakers of
Indonesian,
mainly in Indonesia where it's the
national language and the sole official
language.
Why does Indonesian have so many more
second language speakers than native
speakers?
Well,
there are hundreds of languages spoken
in Indonesia and Indonesia and functions
as a Lingua Franca between speakers of
different languages.
It's the language of education and of
media and these days everybody learns
Indonesian,
but most Indonesians still speak a
different regional language as their
native language plus Indonesia.
The national language.
How was the Indonesian language born?
Indonesian is based on the Malaya
language,
which has been a Lingua Franca of trade
and of the elite throughout the Malay
archipelago for centuries.
The story of Indonesian begins during
the colonial period in the early 17th
century.
The VOC or the Dutch east India company
established a trading post at Batavia.
The site of Present Day Jakarta and over
the following three centuries expanded
into other areas of present day
Indonesia.
The Dutch east India company made Molay
the administrative language of its
trading outpost.
In 1799,
the Dutch east India company went
bankrupt and the Dutch government took
control of the colony in the late 18th
century.
The British east India company had also
arrived in the archipelago and an 18,
24,
a treaty between the British and the
Dutch divided the area between the
British to the north and the Dutch to
the south in the Dutch colony,
the promotion of the Dutch language and
education and Dutch began,
but only to a limited extent,
mostly for the elite compared to other
colonial powers.
The Dutch were not really interested in
changing the culture of the colonized
people.
Their main goal was to facilitate trade,
therefore,
since Malaya was already a Lingua Franca
that could facilitate trade,
there was no reason for them to
introduce Dutch as a Lingua Franca.
The Dutch promoted Malaya as the
language of education,
recognizing referral molay,
the classical Malays spoken in the
Malacca and Johor,
nate's as the standard language,
the standard form of Malaya continue to
develop with the abundance of Malaya
literature.
In the 19th century into the 20th
century,
molay linguists published dictionaries
and grammars to further standardize and
modernize the language.
The Dutch language never became
widespread in Indonesia.
In fact,
in 1940,
only two percent of Indonesians spoke
Dutch,
but even though the role of the Dutch
language was very limited,
a large number of Dutch loan words
entered the Malay language in the areas
under Dutch control,
and this is one of the things that made
the Indonesian variety of Malaya
different from other varieties.
In the early 20th century,
Pro Independence Movement arose and
people throughout the Dutch colony began
to see themselves as a single people,
Indonesians.
The term Indonesia was a new term for
the archipelago created by European
ethnologists,
but adopted by nationalists in the Dutch
colony at the Youth Conference of
Nineteen Twenty eight.
Young nationalists declared the youth
pledge with three ideals,
one motherland,
one nation,
and one language.
The language they chose was the
Indonesian variety of Malaya,
which they named Bahasa,
Indonesia.
When Indonesia declared independence in
1945,
Indonesian was declared the national
language of the new country,
but why Indonesian?
At the time of independence,
Indonesian was the native language of
only five percent of the population.
While Japanese was the native language
of over 40 percent of the population.
So why wasn't Japanese chosen to be the
national language?
Well,
that would've shown favoritism to
Indonesia is the largest ethnic group
undermining the national unity of the
country,
but Indonesian previously known just as
Molay had been a lingua Franca
throughout the archipelago for
centuries.
So people in various regions of the
country already knew some molay.
It was also a much simpler language than
Japanese and could realistically be
learned by millions of people as a
second language.
Indonesian turned out to be the right
choice,
successfully becoming the language of
government education,
trade and communication between people
in different regions of the country.
Indonesian completely replaced the form
of colonial language,
Dutch as the language of public life,
and that's something that's very rare
and former colonies today.
Indonesian is still the second language
of most Indonesian people,
but it's becoming increasingly more
common as a native language,
especially in the cities.
That's because people from all over the
country moved to the big cities,
so rather than speak their native
regional languages that they speak
Indonesian instead and some of them get
married with each other and they raised
their children speaking Indonesian as
their primary language.
So what is Indonesian like?
Well,
undoubtedly one of the things that made
Indonesian so successful as a national
language so quickly was it simplicity?
If you've seen my video on molay than
you're already familiar with the
simplicity of Indonesian because in its
standard form it's very close to
standard Malai just with some different
vocabulary.
Here are some features of Indonesian
Indonesian has simple phonology.
Orthography in general,
one letter represents just one cell.
Indonesian has simple Svo sentence
structure.
There are no case inflections in
Indonesian,
there is also no grammatical,
gender and Indonesian.
There's no plural form and Indonesian
and explicit plurals are made
duplications.
Reduplicate,
meaning that you repeat the word again
and perhaps best of all,
no verb conjugations.
Let's look at a few Indonesian sentences
and we'll identify some of those
features.
Sure.
This sentence means they are cooking
eggs for breakfast,
word for word it.
They now cooked egg for breakfast.
We can see that this sentence is Svo.
As I said before,
there are no verb conjugations,
so how do we know that this action is
happening now?
Well,
it's because of this word right here.
Sit down.
This is an adverb that indicates that
something is happening right now.
You can change the tense of the verb by
changing this adverb.
Here's another sentence,
but it goes to the after changing the
word sit down to Suda.
The sentence now means they cooked eggs
for breakfast in the past tense.
The adverb Suda means something like
already and shows that an action has
been completed.
How about the future tense,
but it got kind of a must have to lose
here.
ICON is the future adverb.
Another example,
separate.
Discerning,
Bulibar,
Colombo.
This means like me,
he often travels to loan book word for
word.
It's like I.
He often traveled to loan book.
Another example of Tacoma Mall.
Do this means do you want to sit up up
is a yes or a no question marker,
so word for word it's question you want
sit,
but up as often left out in speech and
notice that to express desire.
You can just add my own right before
another verb.
The second verb doesn't change its form
at all.
Another example,
Siama newly.
This means I write letters for my friend
word for word.
It's I write a letter for friend.
I noticed that the word for letters
Sudip is the same as the singular form.
Also noticed that possession is shown by
placing a personal pronoun right after
announcing to Mon Cya.
Literally friend.
I means my friend.
This makes it quite easy to form
possessives.
Another example.
Scientists who come down.
This means,
I don't like eating peanuts word for
word.
It's,
I know like eat peanut,
so we negate a sentence by adding t dot
before the verb,
and notice that similar to the word
mouth,
which means once we can express like by
placing the word Sukar right before
another verb got Joan Suda.
This means the peanuts have already been
eaten word by word.
It's peanuts already be eaten.
The icon is a passive.
Let's take a look at some of the verbs
from the above sentences.
You can see that these Indonesian verbs
have two parts of root in black and an
ethics in red Indonesian has many such
affixes that are added to routes to make
verbs and nouns.
One example,
the root Dooley's meaning to right,
we have to write the two lists to be
written that the police to be written to
listen,
something that's written when normally
scan to write something down,
but no lease a writer,
but no listen the process of writing,
but at the least to have written on it,
but the lesson with the writing or
words,
you can see more examples of such
affixes in my video on Malave,
which functions in the same way affix is
of the most challenging part of learning
Indonesian,
at least for a lot of learners,
but you can make use of that feature of
the roots and affixes to help you learn
new words through their connections with
other words.
Standard Indonesian really is a simple
language compared to other languages,
but that's standard Indonesia,
which is normally used as the written
language and informal context.
The Way Indonesian is spoken in daily
life is often fairly different from
standard Indonesian,
different varieties of colloquial
Indonesian or spoken around the country
and they're influenced by the local
native language that area,
these different varieties of Indonesian
or referred to as Bahasa gold.
The Bahasa goal of Jakarta is influenced
by Battelle.
We the Malay Creole language that's
native to Jakarta as well as by Javanese
and Sudanese.
Since people from all over Indonesia
moved to Jakarta.
Let's look at the Bahasa gavel of
Jakarta and see how it differs from
standard Indonesian.
Here's a sentence we looked at before my
name now in Bahasa gold medal.
The first difference we see is that the
word sit down,
which indicates present tense is like in
Bahasa gold.
Luggy is also used in standard
Indonesian to me and again or still,
but it's not used as a present tense
marker like this.
Another difference is that the verb is
used in its root form muscle without the
prefix.
Then we have a sound difference in the
world to Lord,
which becomes like to lower and then
took becomes bulla which can be used in
standard Indonesian,
but the meaning is more like in order to
in Bahasa got well you can use it to
simply mean for,
but it got sued.
Now in Bahasa goal,
but a code here,
notice that the word pseudo is reduced
to Buddha,
but got now in Bahasa gold may come back
and here,
notice that the future marker icon
becomes buckle.
Another example,
separate these setting now in Bahasa.
Goal yet gooey.
Yes,
setting,
reboot and Colombo.
The first difference here is that the
word solidity,
meaning like changes to Kayak.
Then notice that sale becomes Gui,
which is a lone word from battalion in
beverly becomes the boot on the root is
the same,
but the graphics are different.
Do in this example,
we'll see two variations of Bahasa gold.
The first variation is a simple casual
sentence going to duke that notice that
the yes or no question marker isn't
there.
Instead at the end you see God,
which means no in Bahasa Dell,
so it's like you want to sit.
No.
The second variation is used for close
friends or people the same age as you
are younger.
Lumada,
loopnet.
The second person Pronoun is loop,
which I believe is a lone word from
Chinese,
which is present in the battalion we
creole language of Jakarta.
In this example,
let's look at some options for first
person pronouns.
Siama men who weren't really suited what
the manway in a casual,
polite sentence you use,
even in Bahasa gold in a more casual,
familiar sentence,
aclu is used,
and when who is used as a possessive,
a shortened form is attached to the end
of the Nell in a more intimate sentence,
grew up or way is used,
also noticed that monopolies loses its
prefix,
but it doesn't revert to its root form
to lease.
Instead,
it maintains the nasal sound at the
beginning.
One more small difference we can see is
that the word for friend to mine is
pronounced more like two men and another
example.
Scientists who come now in Bahasa gold
item and Kutchan again,
here we see the pronouns blew up and we
see that the negative to that becomes
now,
which is related to the word God,
which we saw before,
and in Bahasa,
golden Sukkah sometimes becomes the men.
And one last example.
Now in Bahasa goal here,
the only difference is that [inaudible]
becomes Buddha as we saw before.
So you can see that the colloquial
Indonesia Jakarta is fairly different
from standard Indonesia and there are
varieties like this spoken around the
country,
the influence of the other languages of
Indonesia on colloquial Indonesia is one
of the things that sets the language
apart from other varieties of Malaysian
Indonesian is definitely a fun language
to study and communicating with
Indonesians in their national language
and Lingua Franca is an amazing
experience.
The question of the day for Indonesians,
to what extent do you speak standard
Indonesia and to what extent do you
speak Bahasa goal and in what
situations?
Leave your comments down below and for
learners of Indonesian,
what's been your experience
communicating with Indonesian people?
Do you find the standard Indonesian that
you learn at textbooks to be useful or
do you feel like you should be learning
more of the language as it's really
spoken?
Be sure to follow link focus on
facebook,
twitter and instagram.
And again,
I'd like to say thank you very much to
my patrion supporters,
especially the ones right here on the
screen for their monthly pledges.
Thank you very much and have a nice day.